attendue et espérée vallée du loir a
désormais son guide du routard une
sortie vécue comme un événement une
naissance
comment il est ce bébé ce bébé mais on
l'a attendu 18 mois donc on est
tellement fier de l'avoir enfin en main
c'est une belle belle découverte que de
se promener sur les bords du loir avec
ce guide du routard on est très fiers
c'est au château de châteaudun que ce
guide du routard vallée de loire sera
présenté en grande pompe
un choix qui ne tient pas du hasard
l'édifice du 12e siècle est une page
d'histoire
c'est un monument d'état gérées par le
centre des monuments nationaux
c'est une richesse architecturale à ciel
ouvert puisque vous avez une déclinaison
de plusieurs siècles d'histoire en un
tour de cours à commencer par son donjon
d'époque médiévale jusqu'à la
renaissance qu'elle est longue ville que
l'on illustre ici et c'est en cela aussi
qu'en tant que châteaux de la loire il a
toute sa place dans ce guide
ce guide du routard est né de la volonté
du pays vende du pays du mois et du pays
vallée du loir le loiret notre lien
d'innovation qui va traverser notre
territoire et de par nos richesses
patrimoniales touristique de loisirs de
nature même de notre territoire par sa
gastronomie sur le sud de la vallée du
loir c'est une multitude de richesse qui
100 briques pour pouvoir faire un
magnifique outil tout est fait pour que
ce guide du routard vallée du loir soit
un véritable succès de librairie sont
priés comprimé 4 euros 90